hey 42 here there are an estimated 30
million human slaves in the world today
more than ever before in history the
country of the most slaves is India
welcome to Rick all of Australia's
snakes spiders sharks crocodiles and
poisonous sea creatures combined only
killed five people per year whereas
horseback riding accidents killed 20
Australians per year there is a company
that provides private flight for
individuals who want to join the
mile-high club for a tidy sum of four
hundred and twenty-five dollars you get
a one-hour flight
chocolates champagne under curtain two
surgeons once used a coat hanger brandy
under tube to operate on a collapsed
lung during an aeroplane flight and they
succeeded a bat that dies whilst
roosting will continue to hang upside
down until someone shakes it loose only
one half of a dolphin's brain goes to
sleep at any time this allows dolphins
to sleep underwater without drowning
studies show that if people adjust their
facial expression to reflect in emotion
they actually begin to feel that emotion
male lobsters bladders are in their
heads and when they fight they squirt
each other in the face with Yuri the
strongest muscle in the human body is
the tongue it can lift up to 80 times
its own weight Americans make up 5% of
the world's population yet they produce
35 percent of the world's waste the
water molecule will spend nine days in
the atmosphere two weeks in a river ten
years in a large life run between 3,000
to 5,000 years in an ocean thanks for
the view subscribe for more
see to